m
blanc souhaite c'est que le nez creux
je vois je reconnais la ville est en
face de nous encore plus vers la gauche
tous et toutes les formes assez à gauche
voilà bien la preuve qu'elle est bien un
peu loin devant
par exemple un vol super moyens
c'est en l'église de
c'est joli c'est avec 10 11 octobre aux
gens tout aussi le danger c'est bon
l'avion qui va décoller qui va passer
devant toi reste comme ça tu vas voir en
avion qui va passer devant moustoir
reste cops attanasio qui passe
ac a dû en voir deux oisillons deux
autres printemps grâce à charles picot
d'un côté tandis qu à gauche de 2,5
juste derrière le gâteau entre amis et
vos peurs ça va brouiller ça va briller
série ben je pense à bruille vachement à
la city où vous derrière c'est celui du
tout bagnole le dire j'ai assez peu de
paysages soient derrière derrière les
voitures en tout genre à brasser en
attendre attendre